you're a pretty big online shopper is
that right you know I Amazon Prime
yeah legatee and and I didn't know how
like it invades your life you know
you'll be on Facebook and go oh and add
for sparkly shoes you know I only looked
at this year's once but yet they come at
you again I didn't have these and they
didn't actually they weren't diamond
like until I stepped into them another
underneath
little nugget so I go through it and I'm
coming through and they go boxer briefs
$1 97 Wow and I grew up poor and right
away the mother part of me my mom how
could that be right
$1.00 97 that can't be hit it I go they
I know they won't have my size so I go 6
X quit putting excess on the clothing by
the way put pictures of mammals so 6 X
that would be hard to find 6 at once
yeah that's not easy and so I got a 97
I'm getting you 5 pair that's under $10
yeah
free shipping yeah so I get them I
thought I'd bring them with here are the
6 X 6 X this is 6 X
yeah but look we they're from here I
think it is yeah Maria oh this is a 6 X
in Korea
easy isn't that wild that's insane but
you know what your eyes you know what I
have a goal now anyway I couldn't send
them back I just love them too much
that's the idea that this could be what
I could look like yeah now you're kind
of fondling them you and I have you you
know something you and I have something
in common which is we're both I've heard
you have this experience yes hower then
then people think we are mean people see
me on television they think okay I'm
probably about average height or a
little above average then they meet me
in real life and I'm much taller and
I've heard that happens to you too
yes and people will go you're taller in
person still fat but taller and people
say the weirdest things to you I don't
know if it happens to you but people
will say well I don't care for you but
my wife loves you
yes yes people like will cross a whole
room and go you know other people are
making a fuss but I just have to tell
you I've never seen your show and I
don't know who you are you know like you
made it across a crowded room I know it
to get to me and say you know it's a
horrible feeling because no matter how
its successful which we both have been
lucky enough all three of us sorry
I didn't I can't see him back in me so
you know and you still get hurt by those
silly things I go well tell her I said
hi he goes well we're not together
anymore
it is a weirdo much sense
you